and to my dear friend chancellor harold
martin leader of this great institution
and his fine wife davita thank you all
for hosting us today
you know this outstanding university has
a a great place a special place in my
heart
and it's really such a privilege to be
back i come from a family of proud
aggies and they're proud for a good
reason
a t is not just the largest hbcu in
america but it's one of the greatest
research universities in the world
home to one of north carolina's leading
centers for energy research and
technology development
every year this premier university
produces some of our nation's top
engineers the highest number of black
engineers in the united states and
prepares the next generation of leaders
to confront the most pressing challenges
we face
none more urgent than the climate crisis
folks i would not be where i am today
the first black man to serve as the
administrator of the united states
environmental protection agency if it
were not for the time i spent here at
north carolina a t state university
so to the students here know that you
have the education
know that you have the tools know that
you have the ability not just to excel
but to be extraordinary you have
everything you need to soar and the
world has never needed you more
so never forget that yes indeed your
degree from a historically black
university can take you anywhere
including the white house and now
it's my pleasure to introduce my
governor your governor governor roy
cooper
[Applause]
well thank you administrator rigging i
tell you you just like you did in north
carolina turning around our department
of environmental quality you have turned
around the epa thank you so much for
your great leadership
and i'll tell you his son matthew seven
years old right on the tarmac today
stepped right up
and welcomed the president of the united
states to north carolina and jumped
right in the car with him and that
that is leadership
we're excited
to welcome president joe biden to
greensboro to highlight the investments
he has helped us make
in roads and bridges
in clean transportation and ev charging
stations
in high speed internet access and in
good paying jobs that we're bringing to
both rural and urban north carolina
we are laser focused on strengthening
our economy moving quickly toward a
clean energy future
and recruiting even more
great jobs
thanks to the well-trained
dedicated diverse workforce that we have
and
world-class higher education across our
state
like north carolina a and t state
university uggie prague
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah i did it chancellor martin yeah
companies from across the globe are
choosing to grow and expand in our state
creating american jobs
we're already on pace to have yet
another record-breaking year for new
jobs and capital investment in north
carolina and even through a pandemic
we've announced tens of thousands of
jobs and tens of billions of dollars in
economic investment across our state a
lot of it right here in the triad
this is great news
but we do know that prices for gas and
food are going up and impacting families
and we have to find a way to make basic
necessities more affordable one way is
easing supply chain woes that make goods
more costly and north carolina is
helping we've opened a new intermodal
facility called the carolina connector
and we've upgraded our state ports to
get goods from ship to shelf quicker
both of these can reduce costs
president biden understands the
importance of bringing down consumer
prices while strengthening our country's
infrastructure and our economy and we'll
hear about his latest efforts today
together
together
we can build an even stronger future for
all north carolinians and all americans
i'm so glad to introduce my friend who
is a strong advocate for the triad and
for north carolina congresswoman kathy
manning
[Applause]
good afternoon
i am so proud to welcome president biden
to beautiful greensboro north carolina
and to north carolina a t state
university and i am not going to compete
with the governor and the way he said
aggie pride so just imagine that an
octave higher
i want to thank president biden for his
leadership and for making the trip here
today
to witness all the great things
happening in the triad in the last few
months
our region has seen some very exciting
economic announcements that will bring
thousands of good paying jobs to this
area these announcements have included
advanced manufacturing jobs at the first
toyota automotive electric battery
manufacturing plant in the country
at a boom supersonic airline
manufacturing facility also the first in
the country that will add good paying
jobs to our innovative and growing
aerospace industry which will be
headquartered at the piedmont triad
international airport we've seen
expansions to existing industries in our
region ranging from textiles to
microchips that create american
american-made goods
these exciting developments are
bolstered by the 10.4
billion dollar investment in north
carolina's infrastructure that was made
possible by the passage of the
bipartisan infrastructure law which i
was proud to support
since president biden signed that bill
into law
we've already seen investments in our
community that are improving the quality
of our roads and bridges
expanding access to broadband and
increasing electric vehicle charging
infrastructure
democrats are delivering on our promise
to improve our nation's outdated
infrastructure and here in the triad
these investments are increasing the
quality of life for residents improving
transit for local businesses and
creating jobs i'm proud to welcome as my
guests some of our communities great
business leaders these leaders run
businesses that range in size from a few
dozen employees to a few thousand
our businesses are innovative they
provide good paying jobs and we in the
triad are proud to continue our strong
history of manufacturing things for the
american people
throughout the pandemic our businesses
adapted to produce essential ppes to
keep our hospital and front line workers
safe to overcome supply chain challenges
and to continue employing members of our
community during times of economic
hardship
they're all shining examples of the best
of what north carolina has to offer
as we stand on the campus of north
carolina amt state university
i am inspired to think about the next
generation of engineers and scientists
and teachers and nurses and business
innovators we are educating who will
lead us into the future and we have just
met with some of those students and they
are extraordinary
i look forward to working with our
president to bring down our costs so
that our young people and people all
across the triad can thrive
in congress i've introduced legislation
to cap out-of-pocket costs for
prescription medications to ensure that
people can afford the medication they
need to stay healthy i've supported an
increase in pell grants so more students
can afford higher education i've
supported funding for more
apprenticeship programs and community
colleges so our students can gain the
skills they need for the good jobs we
already have and the jobs we will grow
in this area and i've advocated for
creative solutions to lower the cost of
essential goods such as gas and
groceries
early in the pandemic i asked president
biden to sign a buy america executive
order so that our local manufacturers
could continue employing our local
residents while adapting their
businesses to meet our nation's ppe
needs and i'm glad to say that president
biden did sign that executive order and
it has resulted in continued growth of
american manufacturing
since then i have supported passage of
the america competes act which will
create jobs strengthen american
manufacturing
sharpen our technological edge and make
strategic investments in our nation's
future
i have two amendments included in the
competes act to help american businesses
attract the best and the brightest
talent to bolster
hbcu like north carolina a t
to also help minority serving
institutions tribal colleges and
american manufacturing
and i was thrilled to bring more than
16.4
million dollars in community project
funding to our community that will help
us with projects ranging from a new 911
dispatch system to electric buses to
access the internet in under served
areas to summer tutoring programs that
will help our students who experienced
learning loss during the pandemic i will
continue to work with president biden
and my colleagues in congress to invest
in our communities to lower costs for
working families and to create jobs here
at home
once again i want to thank president
biden for his leadership and for
allowing me to be here today to
highlight some of the many reasons that
i am proud to represent this community
in congress the future is bright in
greensboro north carolina thank you all
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
please welcome north carolina
agricultural and technical state
university student malcolm hawkins
[Applause]
good afternoon to all in attendance
my name is malcolm hawkins and i'm a
senior electrical engineering student
here at north carolina agricultural and
technical state university
i'm truly honored to welcome president
biden to this illustrious institution
when i made the decision to attend a
north carolina anc i was excited for the
journey to come
i look forward to learning as much as i
could so that i would excel upon
graduation
after being on campus for four years i
can certainly attest to the excellent
education that an hbcu provides
i've been taught by dedicated professors
and mentored by individuals who saw my
potential to positively impact this
world
i've interned at four different
companies participated in and won a
national competition and traveled abroad
this and so much more is possible by
investment in hbcus
north carolina ant graduates the highest
number of african american engineers and
they go on to have successful careers in
government industry and academia
there is always a need for problem
solvers
who can tackle the most difficult issues
including those involving the economy
and hbcus prepares students for the
challenge
the key to this preparation is
innovation
whether that's through our many centers
of excellence or the new haraldo martin
senior engineering research and
innovation complex ant students
regardless of major graduate with the
skills needed to transform their
respective fields
needless to say as i graduate next month
i feel fully equipped with the knowledge
i need to excel in all aspects of my
life i'm excited to see hbcus continue
to rise in prominence and i can't wait
to see how they impact america in the
future
with that
please give a warm welcome to the
president of the united states joe biden
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello hello greensboro
chancellor
please take a seat if you have one
i said that one day take a seat the
press pointed out to me there were no
chairs out there
thank you very very much for the
opportunity to be here chancellor thank
you and
thank your wife as well for all you do
for uh
educating the future of this country
and it's i've been impressed
i've been on a lot of university
campuses matter of fact for four years i
was a full professor at the university
of pennsylvania and this is really an
impressive place
with a lot of impressive students
and it's good to be here at a t and i
thank you for uh
for your sharing your story malcolm he's
gonna
did you say where you're going am i
allowed to say where you're going to be
working
you work at ibm a little outfit you know
that
just remember you're chairman of the
board remember me okay
i go by and say hey malcolm
i says joe here and i want to hear joe
who okay
[Applause]
well mayor vaughan thank you for the
passport into the city
it's great to be here with a
congresswoman who delivers the people
this district kathy you do an incredible
job you know you really do you really do
my dear friend congressman
g.k butterfield what did i see here
there you go man stand up i want you to
stand up this guy
he's done
he's done so much over this
distinguished career for the last 20
years or so i wish you weren't leaving
pal
i wish you weren't leaving but i
understand and i uh but thanks for all
you've done
and congrats from alba uh asking me alma
adams where's it where's she there you
are i see the hat what am i talking
about
alma how are you you're the best
thank you for all the hard work delivery
hpcus not just this but all across the
country thank you thank you thank you
and your outstanding governor one of the
best governors in the entire united
states of america i say that without
reservation governor roy cooper dove
[Applause]
the war has proven himself to be not a
joke one of the finest governors in the
nation he's displayed
so many talents he's deployed funding
for american rescue plan to deliver
debt-free community college for young
people in north carolina he's delivered
high-speed internet rural communities
he's delivered well-deserved raise for
teachers and first responders and thanks
for making a difference for the families
here in north carolina governor you're
setting an example across the country
thank you
and look you can cheer it's all right
[Applause]
there's a debate in my administration
that we never seem to be able to sell
and that is that uh
the vice president is incredibly
talented
she's a howard graduate
a great school
and i hear about morehouse men from my
senior advisor cedric richmond all the
time
and you've got a great university here
but delaware state
delaware state
they launched me into my career not a
joke
as i got elected at the united states
senate when i was 29 years old
chancellor
had to wait 17 days to be eligible to be
sworn in true story
and it wouldn't have happened and i won
by a rousing
3021 votes
and uh it wouldn't happen without
delaware state
most people don't realize is delaware
has the eighth largest black population
in america
and uh the fact is that uh as i say in
claim on delaware where i was raised a
little steel town in delaware
you all bring me to the dance and uh but
here's the deal
i got a member of my cabinet who is also
slightly partial on north carolina amt
administrator for environmental
protection michael regan
of course you never hear michael
bragging about the place
as long as you don't have your hearing
aid on
but look
he's a proud aggie
and uh welcome back to the campus
michael and uh let me tell you talking
about some incredible students here
today
i know why michael's so proud of this
school i really mean it and
a and t is an extraordinary
extraordinary
university with a great tradition an
hbcu tradition you know more than 180
years of excellence
delivering
on that sacred promise
we made in america that every american
every race every background every zip
code
should have
should have
a fair and equal chance to go as far as
their god-given talents can take them
and you're providing that here
chancellor
because there's so many so many great
professors here and the program here so
strong you're giving people an
opportunity
to take advantage of their god-given
talents
that's why i reestablished the
president's board of advisors on hbcus
but not one
but two north korean int alums
on it willie dees
and janine gizmo
are you here are they here
stand up rory stand up julian
thank you
[Applause]
it also includes a proud north carolina
native an nba star chris paul
he's on it
by the way he's a hell of a ball player
who supports the business course here at
a t and is a fierce champion for all
hbcus
that's why i signed an executive order
to advance hbcu excellence across the
entire administration
everything from policies to funding
and speaking of funding we were able to
deliver more than 5 billion
last year to hbcus and more to come this
year 5 billion
[Applause]
and they said we couldn't do it
[Applause]
but everybody's realized what an
incredible asset to hbcus
we're also working to increase increased
pell grants to help millions of black
students and lower income families
attend community colleges and four-year
schools the reason my wife is not with
me today she's a community college
professor and she's teaching as we speak
i'm here today to talk about my plan to
create and expand hbcu programs in high
demand fields like cyber security
advanced manufacturing healthcare and so
much more
and to talk about why it's so critical
that we have to invest in american
manufacturing
and if my my dad were watching now he
passed away and watching he
said
you know why it's essential that the
congress take action quickly to support
american innovation
i said today at the when i was uh uh
we're at the cyber security unit
that more is going to change in the next
10 years
that's changed in the last 50 years
science technology is moving so
incredibly rapidly
it's all part of a broader vision that
vice president harris and i ran on
to build back a better america than even
before the
pandemic a better way with better pay
greater dignity for working people
easing the financial burdens of millions
of families
making it in america as your
congresswoman said with american
manufacturing
the best engineers in the world like so
many here at aet graduates
make up that cadre
from day one
every action i've taken to rebuild our
economy has been guided by one principle
made in america it means using products
parts and materials built right here in
the united states america it means
bringing manufacturing jobs back
and building supply chains here at home
not outsourced from abroad
it means letting and betting on american
workers let them do the job and bet on
them
and it takes a federal government it
doesn't just give lip service to buy an
american but actually takes action
most people don't know i know the
congresswoman knows there's been a law
in the book since the late 30s
that says that
you can use american tax dollars
and if you're american tax dollars the
president is spending it should be spent
on american products
american products american businesses
every administration says they'll do it
since the late 30s
but now over time buy america has become
basically a hollow promise
my administration is making buy america
a reality
we created made in america
in an office in the white house a made
in america office to oversee these
efforts
you know what's happened is that the
exception used to be if you want to if
the president spends about six to seven
hundred billion dollars a year money on
federal projects every year from effects
of aircraft carriers to so much more
and
it's supposed to buy american businesses
american products
but the fact of the matter is that there
was an exception if you couldn't readily
find an american institution neither had
this part of the supply chain and or the
company you didn't have to you could buy
it abroad you could import it
well last month i announced one of the
biggest changes in the buy american act
in 70 years
each year the federal government spends
more than 600 billion dollars on goods
and services
and in the past if the manufacturing
product that you get purchased by the
federal government says it is
substantially all
made all in there substantially all in
america it worked
but because of loopholes over time
you know what substantially all meant
when i took office been at 55 of the
product
was made up of american business
american product it was substantially
all an american product
well guess what to me 55 isn't
substantially all it's slightly over
half
and so we issued a rule
raise the amount of domestic content
required to be considered made in
america from 55 to 75
substantially all is going to start
meaning substantially all
and that's good for american workers and
for american businesses for communities
like greensboro
and i want to thank congresswoman
manning for who's been the strong strong
supporter by america
now we're seeing the results of our
economic vision
our economy created
431 000 jobs in the month of march alone
431 000
7.9 million jobs over the course of my
presidency
more jobs in the 14 months i've been
president than any president ever
created in american history unemployment
at six point at 3.6 percent
is down from 6.4
when we took office 14 months ago
it's the fastest decline in unemployment
to start a president's terms have
recorded
north carolina thanks to the american
rescue plan and the leadership of
governor cooper has added 194
000 jobs in the last 14 months
194 thousand dollars
good job
that's 67 000 jobs ahead of where the
state was before the pandemic hit
and unlike the past recoveries
this time around with the american
rescue plan we made a choice to bring
everyone along
so not only has unemployment rate
dropped for at a record pace here in
north carolina and across the nation
but black unemployment fell by more than
30 percent more than 30 percent
[Applause]
hispanic unemployment fell from nearly 9
to 4.2 percent in the year 2021
the fastest single drop ever recorded
we had the largest one-year drop in
long-term unemployment ever recorded in
american history
look folks
[Applause]
because the child tax we've seen the
lowest child poverty rate ever projected
an estimated nearly 40 percent decline
in child poverty
the lowest number of home foreclosures
ever recorded
a record low credit card delinquency is
because families have more money in
their pockets to pay their bills
the list goes on
all told this economy grew by 5.7
percent last year in 2021 the fastest
growth in 40 years
and in the process
doing all this we still cut the deficit
last year by
350 billion dollars just last year alone
and by an additional one trillion
dollars this year if the budget goes
through
so folks don't tell me we this
trickle-down id is the only way to grow
an economy
we're actually lowering the deficit
not increasing it
and after a long tough stretch
americans are back to work our economy
has gone from being on the mend
being on the move
now i know that we're still facing
challenges of high prices inflation
i grew up in a family
where when the price of gasoline went up
at the pump
it was a conversation at the kitchen
table with my dad
putin's invasion of ukraine
has driven up gas prices and food prices
all over the world
ukraine and russia are the one and two
largest wheat producers in the world
we're number three
they're shut down
we saw that yesterday's inflation data
what people don't know is it 70
percent of the increase in inflation was
the consequence of putin's price site
because of the impact on oil prices 70
percent
we need we need to address these high
prices and urgently
for working folks out there and that's
part of why
we're talking what i'm going to talk to
you about today why it's so important
when we build more in america
we increase economic capacity and
ultimately it helps lower everyday
prices for families
that's what we're starting to see look
around
american manufacturing is coming back
once again we're seeing the pride that
comes from stamping a product made in
america
companies are choosing to build their
new factories here
local charging stations
we're also getting rid of poisonous lead
pipes
that are in 10 million homes in america
and 400 000 schools and day care centers
and there's serious brain damage
not a joke
so kids and families can have
clean drinking water
and this year
north carolina will receive
199 million dollars for clean water
because of that man right there the
governor
folks
[Applause]
we're going to deliver affordable
high-speed internet everywhere
in urban america rural america suburban
and tribal communities
so moms don't have to do this i wonder
if you ever thought this would happen in
america
remember three or four months
two three months ago when schools were
still shut
down showing pictures of moms and dads
driving to the parking lot of mcdonald's
so they could connect the internet so
the kid could do their homework
not a joke
not a joke
what the hell's going on here
all these investments infrastructure
research and development
and making in america
are really about one thing
empowering more communities
to do what you're doing here in
greensboro
transforming yourself
into a city city of the future not the
past
where
instead of shuttered factories we're
building clean energy technology that's
going to power the future in america and
around the world
helping america achieve true energy
independence by creating good jobs and
fighting for climate change
and if we continue this we're not only
going to be investing here we're going
to export billions of dollars worth of
product
for the rest of the world
one of the proposals i have i won't go
into now is to build back better world
so all those countries in africa and
latin america and the middle east who
don't have the capacity
to make it better for themselves
we cut down all our forests we're doing
fine guess what
we're part of the reason for the global
warming
a lot of poor countries do you realize
the greatest one of the greatest carbon
sinks in the world absorbing carbon from
the air
is the amazon
the amazon absorbs more
pollutants more carbon into the soil and
the and the water in the amazon than
emitted in the entire united states in
one year
every year
they don't have the money
but what they want to do they want to
level it so they can farm it they can
produce things on it and
use up that sink
you know and even reinventing the legacy
industries
that greensburg would build on is
impossibility
with 21 century smart textiles they use
chips and sensors to do things like
regulate temperature in a garment
state-of-the-art
facilities
that make high-quality furniture
above all
you're making greensboro a place where
the future is being written not a joke
the future is being written
for students at great schools like a t
and other local universities and your
incredible community colleges can lead
can lead learning cutting-edge
skills in state-of-the-art facilities
partnering with local employers
so
so look
so they can get out
help america lead the way on robotics
and cyber security and so much
more and see that success reflected back
home in their communities not just in
greensboro but across the country
so families can have good paychecks good
homes great futures
my dad would say
my dad was a
a very well-read man his greatest regret
was he never got to go to college
and my dad
used to say
that everybody deserves just a little
bit of breathing room
just a little bit of breathing room
i was raised in a three bedroom split
level home when we moved down to
delaware and cold died in scranton and
jobs were gone
and uh
with four kids
grandpa and my mom and dad
and i remember one day could always hear
when dad was restless
i asked mom on the way to school what's
the matter he said honey
dad's dad's company just they said no no
no more health insurance
no more health insurance
not only deprives a woman or a man of
their health
but of their dignity
their dignity
look at their child or husband their
wife
who needs help
and can't get to help
one thing we're trying to get done in
the congress is to pass
legislation that is won't raise taxes a
single penny for anybody making less
than 400 grand and above that only be a
mispidgeon
for
dealing with insulin
you got 200 000 kids with type 1
diabetes
they don't get their insulin many of you
may know somebody or you maybe have type
1 diabetes you need the insulin
it costs 10 of vial to make
average price
average price
646 dollars a month
not only imagine what happens when you
don't have that
money because you don't have the
insurance or the
cash imagine being a parent
looking at your child with type 1
diabetes and know there's not a damn
thing you can do
it deprives you your dignity
takes everything away from you
well guess what
for little or nothing
we can limit that price to 35 a month
and they'll still make 350 percent
profit
[Applause]
that's the story we've got to keep
writing
and by the way i'm a capitalist
i'm i'm i'm not somebody who doesn't
think you should be able to go out and
make
you know a million or a billion dollars
just pay your fair share
just pay a little tiny bit
not a joke
the fortune 500 companies and i come
from the corporate capital of the world
not a joke
more companies incorporate in the state
of delaware than the entire united
states of america combined
and i was the senator of 36 years
but guess what
55 of them last year
didn't pay a single penny in tax
and they made 40 billion dollars
so folks look
we have to keep going on so many other
issues that deliver the promise of
america to all americans
for example
equity and opportunity
require more than just
economic investment they require
policing criminal justice reform
even though congress isn't taking action
my administration hears and sees the
people who need it badly
we're making changes in the federal law
police need more money not less in order
to have social workers and others with
them not just and teach them how to do
their job better but also
we need rules
that were that i've initiated in
federally
no more chokeholds no more no knock
warrants requiring federal agents to
wear protective body cameras
we're going to sit back while republican
congress stand in the way
stand in the way of justice i'm sorry to
be partisan about that but they are
they're not they're unwilling to do
anything
we're taking action
today my administration has also
released the first ever equity action
plan
laying out more than 300 concrete
commitments
to tear down the systematic barriers
that have been allowed to fester for far
too long in america things like getting
pollution out of low-income
neighborhoods
you notice they're always the last to
ever be touched
in delaware big chemical industry
well guess what
the corridor that we run down
going down the state
the fence line communities
the cancer rate we have one of the
highest cancer rates in america
why because all these poor communities
live near these stations
near these places
i was growing up in clemont delaware not
a joke
we lived right on the pennsylvania
border it was a steel town
more oral refineries in marcus of
pennsylvania in the ben and dela river
than anywhere including houston
guess what
when it got to be fall i was in fourth
grade
and i got a little frost my mom would
get in the car to drive me to school
which is only three quarters a mile away
but it was on a highway
turn on the windshield there'd be an oil
slick
on the window
that wouldn't have happened where i live
now
in a nice neighborhood never happened
making sure the minority owned business
can access capital
they need to grow
so no community is locked out of
opportunity
look
i'm not saying this because i'm an hbcu
i've been saying this my whole career
when i ran for office i said i'm sick
and tired of trickle down economy
i'm about building from the middle up
and out because when the middle does
well everybody does the poor have a way
up and the wealthy do very well the
bottom line is this
the united states is in the position to
out-compete compete the world once again
we have an incredible opportunity ahead
of us
we still face tremendous challenges
but if we can keep coming together
invest in the backbone of america the
middle class
our great universities hard working
families stem education
clean technologies for tomorrow there's
simply no limit i mean it no limit is
what we can achieve
so let's continue giving working
families a fighting chance
let's keep investing in the future of
this country of every community
and let's face these challenges head on
let's keep building a better america
because that's who we've been
that's who we are
and we can do this
still grow the economy still be the
wealthiest nation in the world still
reduce deficits
by growing
growing growing growing
there's not a single thing america can't
do
when we do it together as the united
states of america
god bless you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
like
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you